We have a voicemail number.
That number is two, one nine two, David p.
Here's a voicemail about maybe, I guess what
we would call it, like a different approach
to getting single payer healthcare going.
Take a look.
Hi David.
My name is [inaudible].
I'm calling from Canada.
I don't have time to get on your show, so
I'm going to give you a message.
Why is the United States getting so hyped
up, oversee over, um, single pair health?
It started in one province in Canada at one
province, and it's spread across the country
little by little.
It wasn't a massive overturn of the country.
It, it only has to start in one state.
Everyone could watch to see how it works.
It doesn't have to be a, uh, a nationwide
experiment.
I do tonight to get your thoughts on this.
Thank you.
Bye. [inaudible] Reni you're, you're not wrong.
But if there's one thing, history has proven
to us, it's that just because Canadians are
able to do something logical doesn't mean
Americans are going to do it just because
Canadians and Australians and Argentinians
and the Swiss and the Swedish and the Norwegians
and the Germans and the French and the Belgians
and the I could go on, right.
Just because they're all able to do something
logical does not mean that the United States
is able to on that basis, and in fact Vermont
was going to do single, a single payer at
the state level under, I believe it was governor
Peter Shumlin, and it ended up falling apart
for a variety of different reasons.
So you're completely right that I would love
to see Massachusetts actually do this.
Massachusetts led the way we had Obamacare
before it was Obamacare.
It was actually Romney care and it was passed
by a very left wing legislature and these
sort of centrists Republican governor, Mitt
Romney.
I would love to see Massachusetts do something
like this and I think we are a prime candidate
to do it.
You're completely right.
States could do it, but looking at other countries
and seeing them act logically, inferring that
the United States can do the same thing historically
has not been a very good way to predict.
Uh, what we're going to do here, we've got
a great bonus show coming up for you today.
Two ways to access it.
Become a member at David Packman,
[inaudible] dot com slash membership become
a patron at patrion.com/david Pakman show
great stories on the bonus show, including
the disappearance of Beto